earlier Pat mentioned this idea that
Donald Trump doesn't seem that involved
with this latest proposal to repeal and
replace the Affordable Care Act from
Republicans called the American Health
Care Act or Republic hair as I am now
calling it the background on this is
that there's actually a number of
conservative groups that are opposed to
the plan put forward by Republicans to
replace to repeal and replace Obamacare
and yesterday Donald Trump met with some
of them at the White House and he has
come up pat with a just brilliant plan
and I'm not actually exaggerating about
calling it brilliant a brilliant plan as
to how to deal with the possible failure
of the new Republican plan if this new
plan fails to pass President Trump says
let's just leave Obamacare in there
it'll continue to fail and then we'll
blame Democrats now it this might sound
a little bit outrageous to you it's
really not as outrageous as it might
sound it's not because in a sense it
could be the best PR move for Trump
although maybe not for Republicans who
will be up for reelection in 18 months
if you pass a republic hair with Obama
care provisions that people like and
want to keep but you get rid of the
mandates and the taxes on the very rich
all of the stuff that you need to pay
for it premiums will explode right
people's plans will cost more
deductibles will go up it'll be a train
wreck if on the other hand you leave
Obamacare functioning putatively
abstence ibly and premiums explode and
it's all a disaster because you figure
out ways to not fund many aspects of it
Trump can then blame Congress generally
for not having passed a replacement but
then he can say hey this is the failed
Democratic Obama plan after all it's
Obama care and maybe he avoids
repercussions for it so he's saying this
behind closed doors with Republicans but
he's also just saying it out in public
he'll ad-lib part of a speech where he
says you know the politically smart
thing to do is just to let Obamacare
fail by itself and we can blame the
Democrats but he doesn't think it's the
right thing to do for the country sure
I'm just flirting with that idea that
you're going to let these premiums and
deductibles
skyrocket for your own political gain
yeah I mean it's it's just it's poor
tactician nning as a as a politician
tactician alike that expect that on
urban dictionary and attributed to you
very very soon what isn't being talked
about much is that
remember when Trump campaigned that he
had a plan to fix health care now he's
not even hiding the fact that
congressional Republicans came up with
this plan
and it happens to be a plan that has
huge conservative opposition trumpets
should realize that hey Trump lied to
you he never had a plan because if he
had a plan he would actually seem to be
involved with what's going on now unless
unless he has a plan he's allowing the
Republican plan to be out there it's not
going to happen as written because so
many conservative groups are opposed and
maybe then Trump can come in pat he can
swoop in and say hey Republicans you
couldn't get it done the Democratic plan
is failing I have the plan and maybe he
becomes sort of like the white knight
that comes in and saves everybody I
don't know we'll remember the 60 Minutes
interview that he gave where he said
that his plan was just to have everyone
be covered everyone to be able to keep
their plans and their doctors and
everyone can have everything everybody
can have everything but it's just gonna
cost way less and it's gonna be way
better for everybody this thing called
basic arithmetic like assets and
liabilities or rather inflows and
outflows explains why you just can't do
that and big picture this is sort of
representative Trump saying hey I'll
just blame Democrats if we can't get
this thing done well Oh Bob we'll just
blame Democrats for failed Obamacare
this has always been Trump's plan take
credit for anything that goes well even
if it's something that was caused by
President Obama and then blame other
people for anything that doesn't work in
case in point GM announced this week
that they're cutting 1,100 jobs from an
American Factory due to low demand for
some of their cars you're never gonna
hear about that from Trump but you will
hear from him when you know a Ford
announces a plan that they've been
planning for years that had nothing to
do with Trump to add some jobs in
Indiana or wherever it is another really
interesting aspect of this meeting where
Trump said hey I'll just blame Democrats
if things failed
happen is something I'm gonna read to
you from the the CNN report about this
take a listen to this confident that the
health care plan will pass the house
Trump laid out his strategy for winning
passage in the Senate telling the
meeting he will campaign heavily in red
states featuring vulnerable Democrats up
for re-election quote Trump said he will
have football stadium events in states
where he won by 10 to 12 points and he's
going to dare people to vote against him
a source at the meeting said perpetual
campaign season right Trump held rallies
between Election Day and inauguration
day Trump held a rally after
inauguration day a few weekends ago in
Florida and it's gonna be perpetual
campaign mode and I'll remind you this
doesn't always work George W Bush in
2005 was trying to sell the country on
privatizing Social Security which
fortunately didn't work he toured the
country trying to garner support for
that and it backfired completely on him
and also once you become president
there's far less excitement so I don't
know if he's going to be able to draw
the same crowds that he did as a
candidate yeah especially if his
approval numbers continue to dip into
the 40s and 30s and especially if it
becomes difficult to just talk about
Hillary Clinton at every rally to get
people cheering and screaming and that
type of thing so yes Trump proposing as
another yet quote solution to whatever
problem comes up turning the presidency
into perpetual campaign mode which it
basically is the Twitter usage hasn't
changed he keeps doing rallies he keeps
making completely baseless allegations
about what other people have done or are
doing it's perpetual campaign
he's already filed for re-election yes
he does and for financial reasons on
inauguration day filing for re-election
hey it's a plan at least if only a PR
plan